look Andrew's not a dummy he's probably
one of the smartest dudes
um I've met he's clearly shown himself
to be an incredible marketer he's
manipulated the media he's manipulated
um icons with large followings talk
about him and here we are talking about
him on my channel again and by the way
my entire feat the last day on YouTube
when I went to the home page was people
talking about Andrew Tate the real
reason why he was incarcerated the title
of the video is some click bait uh
thumbnail or some [ __ ] like that idiots
that don't know him that have never
talked to him but
even the ones that have talked to him
it's like okay here we go here we go
what are we going to speculate on today
what's what's the red meat where's the
car accident let's all take a look at it
off to the side of the road today Andrew
and Tristan incarcerated for the next 30
days apparently look I don't know what
happened
um
I talked to him on WhatsApp uh not that
often he's quite busy doing what he does
these days but he does respond if I do
message and he's he's been great the
last couple years
um you know chatting to and having him
on as a guest from time to time for
podcast I think he's funny isn't it one
of his favorite interviews I'll say it
again if you haven't seen it go watch
the one with Tom Segura on your mom's
house uh it's hilarious
so
I don't know what's uh you know what's
gone down
I suspect because he is perspicious as
he likes to say that he was aware of his
surroundings and I don't think it was a
surprise to him uh it didn't have
anything to do with the stupid pizza box
regretta I don't think I mean when you
fly into a country they know that you're
there right it's not like you can slip
it under the radar with a stealth
private jet I mean you you get it and
you deal with custom stuff they know
that you're there so
they knew that he was there wasn't like
oh they found him because of his pizza
boxes and Kerry's pizza if you can start
a [ __ ] gullible man I'll tell you
they fall for some weird [ __ ]
um
I'm sure he'll be fine
I will say this though like if they keep
him for 30 days
I think he's the kind of guy that will
probably say you know what [ __ ] this
and just tell everything and and just
move it to another location that's not
going to treat him like that
um if you heard his original story about
why he left England it's basically
because of you know a corrupt
uh legal system that panders to the
female first primary social order
anytime it says jumped then the order
says how high and responds accordingly
that's that's basically why he left
um you know the UK he had a
he had a false allegation thrown against
him from one of his uh webcam girls and
he said [ __ ] this amount
so I would not be surprised if um you
know he's detained for the entire 30
days that he at some point makes an uh
exit I know what he did I mean it's the
same charge they pulled
what was it back in the summertime or
spring
um human trafficking or some [ __ ] and
the total story with that was there were
some random American hoe that ended up
at his place partying showing it on
stories
um boyfriend confronted her about it and
she lied and said that she was kidnapped
so he calls the American Embassy
American Embassy calls the Romanian
Embassy they take him away for whatever
period of time couple hours a day and
they let him go because it wasn't the
case so this is the exact same charge is
what I'm hearing again
so here we are
I'm sure he's fine
I'm sure I mean clearly
clearly he's on the radar screen
you want to go full 10 tin foil hat
maybe the Americans maybe the powers
that be maybe the Matrix is in fact fed
up with him and following through on
step two remember step one was a cancel
step two he said was to incarcerate him
step three is to kill
maybe they're going through with step
two maybe maybe this is what this
project is doesn't seem like it's uh
that far out of the question it's
entirely plausible it is what it is
but uh I'm sure it'll be fine
um you know he's a big boy and he knows
what he's doing he's smart a lot smarter
than people give him credit for and he's
a master marketer like I can like the
whole thing with Greta I thought was
hilarious because I knew exactly what he
was doing he was just leveraging what he
exactly she was going to do in response
to get her to engage him to grab the
attention of some of her audience right
to get them talking about that and that
shows up in the news and it shows up
with other podcasters or other
influencers if you will talking about
the whole notion idea too he's very very
smart he's a smart dude knows exactly
what he's doing so hat tip he'll be out
soon though
yeah yeah it's funny that um yeah people
in the comments going about you know the
whole Epstein thing it's like you know
it's real funny that all of these guys
um that are that are part of the uh the
Epstein Clan the visitors to his Island
no names have been revealed nobody's
been convicted just you know whatever
the dude conveniently hung himself and
um that was the end of it but there's an
allegation thrown against a guy who
seems like a pretty good dude in fact it
seems highly unlikely that anything that
they've charged them with is a real
charge based on what I know
um but who knows you know there could be
there could be some [ __ ] behind the
scenes you know as they always say
evidence has a way of of coming to us
over time
um You Can't Hide [ __ ] so I mean he
looks he'll he'll probably in my
estimation expose the [ __ ] I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full-length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out